well one thing I've been working on
lately I've been sort of involved in the
not-for-profit world on two fronts one
is I've been working with bono old
friend and he has gotten me involved in
terms of helping him reorganize and move
forward with this sort of little
ecosystem he's developed along with the
Gates Foundation and George Soros and
Warren Buffett and people like that
which is really about raising awareness
raising money and allocating money in a
smart way against the extreme poor and
in his case it's in this sub-saharan
Africa so he's got data which is a
lobbying and activist it's it's a
basically a lobbying and policy shop
there's one which is this consumer
activist organization and there's this
thing called red product red you might
have seen the windows in the gap which
basically tries to tap in the consumer
spending power that goes on where a
certain portion of profits get sent
directly to the Global Fund and get
allocated for in this case
antiretroviral drugs for people with HIV
and AIDS so I've been helping them find
people to run these companies and
reorganize the way that they're
currently set up so they can sort of
take themselves to a different level of
effectiveness and I would just say as a
plug for them they've accomplished so
much it's really quite impressive story
to date and a lot of smart dedicated
people have been working on this problem
now very actively since last six or
seven years I'm also have been I've
returned recently a couple of times to
Afghanistan which is a place I lived in
for many years in the 70s and I've been
involved there with both some specific
reconstruction efforts and talking to
various people there about what that
country needs and how I might be able to
help
terms of making the kind of connections
as they almost start over again after 30
years of war so those have been you know
two things that have been someone
gratifying to me and quite different
from what I did in my prior career I
feel good I mean look I was on a very
fast-paced job in LA MTV MTV Networks
been as you know see chief operating
officer chief executive officer of
Viacom running a public company very big
responsibility a lot of things about
that life that are enjoyable but at the
same time I do find that after 26 years
it's like you know as a long time to do
anything a quarter of a century so and I
had a life before I had a career in life
before I even started in that business
so I've always been a fan I've always
said you know you should do several
different things in your life have a
bunch of different chapters or parts and
sometimes maybe you just need to be
kicked into the next part or you know
just for sake of comfort or repetition
you end up doing the same thing maybe
longer than you should so exhilarated
now it's been been an adjustment period
but I but I feel every day when I get up
I'm going to do things that I'm really
you know passionate about or care about
and there's a portfolio of things that
that I isn't as someone saying well you
have this job so this is a bunch of
problems you have to deal with I'm not
so much in that defensive mode at the
moment which is the case for most people
who say if you're a CEO of a public
company a lot of it you're playing
defense you're dealing with problems or
crises at the moment and the smaller
life I have for myself I've got a lot
less of that which is a good thing